aquí tenemos un problema bien
interesante dado este diagrama de aquí
debemos determinar la longitud dcf y al
parecer este problema tiene que ver con
triángulos semejantes porque parece que
los triángulos a b y c
efe son semejantes y asimismo parece que
los triángulos de eb y cfb también son
semejantes bueno entonces vamos a ver
que en efecto esos triángulos que dije
son semejantes y bueno una vez que
tengamos eso podremos usar las razones
de los triángulos para determinar la
longitud dcf vale bueno vamos a empezar
mostrando que el triángulo a b
es semejante al triángulo c efe observa
que tienen este ángulo recto en común
aquí tenemos este ángulo recto y aquí
también así que bastaría encontrar un
ángulo más para concluir que son
semejantes porque podríamos utilizar el
criterio ángulo ángulo pero ve aquí en
también tenemos este ángulo en común si
entonces este ángulo en e pues es ángulo
común para ave y para cf
en uno es el ángulo b y en otro es el
ángulo fs y entonces ya concluimos que
ave es semejante a cf porque tienen dos
ángulos correspondientes que son
congruentes vale entonces déjame apuntar
esto por acá arriba tenemos que el
triángulo
y es semejante al triángulo hay que ser
cuidadosos verdad vamos de aquí al
ángulo recto y luego al ángulo azul
entonces vamos de aquí al alce al ángulo
recto efe
y finalmente el ángulo azul
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos estos dos
triángulos semejantes vamos a ver ahora
que este pequeño triángulo el cfv es
semejante al triángulo d
b es decir este triángulo pequeño de acá
déjame lo marcó un poco más claro este
de acá es semejante al grande vale y
cómo le hacemos pues misma idea este
ángulo de aquí a recto ahora este ángulo
de acá es recto verdad de este lado
porque es rector del de la derecha
entonces una vez más tenemos que los
ángulos rectos pues son iguales y además
ahora comparten este ángulo de acá el
ángulo en b vale entonces los triángulos
cfb i d y b también son semejantes
déjame apuntarlo por entonces el
triángulo
el triángulo de v d
b es semejante al triángulo cfb al
triángulo c
efe ve muy bien entonces ya que tenemos
estas semejanzas podemos utilizarlas
para ver que los lados correspondientes
tienen la misma proporción y vamos a
utilizar eso para resolver el problema
pero al parecer tenemos muy poca
información no más tenemos que este mide
9 y este mide 12 y eso justo es lo que
hace que este problema sea tan
desafiante pero bueno no hay que
rendirnos y para eso lo que vamos a
hacer es poner un nombre a algunas de
las longitudes que nos interesan
entonces déjame poner que el lado b me
deje vamos a ponerle esa medida y a lo
mejor con un poco de suerte podremos
terminar el problema utilizando eso vale
entonces aquí déjame ponerle ya y además
parece ser que sería bueno tener esta
longitud de vf entonces a esa déjame
ponerle x entonces aquí le voy a poner
que esto me dé
esto mide x también va a ser útil tener
efe le podríamos poner una tercera letra
como z pero como todo esto ya me deje y
esto mide x entonces podemos concluir
que f
efe mide y de menos x vale porque las
dos tienen que sumar que bueno entonces
ahí tenemos x y yemen os x y ahora con
estas variables y estos números vamos a
ver qué nos dicen las semejanzas vamos a
empezar poniendo pues hace efe en algún
lado vale porque es importante que se f
aparezca entonces vamos a hacer cf
vamos a utilizar esta semejanza vale
entonces vamos a poner a cf / ave entre
vea que son los lados correspondientes
de esta semejanza entonces tenemos que
cf cf / ave entre ave que es 9 que es 9
es igual a gm x lo voy a poner en color
verde
gm x dividido entre el lado
correspondiente que tendría que ser este
de acá el b y el bm
vale entonces sería menos x entre ella y
eso sale a partir de la semejanza de
este triángulo vamos a ver si podemos
obtener algo similar con la semejanza de
acá entonces una vez voy a utilizarse
una vez más voy a utilizarse efe que es
lo que nos interesa entonces voy a poner
voy a poner
efe
efe / ahora el lado correspondiente es
de que mide 12 12
esto de aquí es igual a y entonces ahora
como está ahora tenemos a x verdad ahora
este es el lado de este triángulo
pequeño entonces sería igual a x entre y
una vez más el lado grande mide a x
entre y bueno aquí parece que las cosas
están complicando porque tenemos dos
ecuaciones y tenemos tres variables cf
y equis entonces parece ser que pues
puede que no lo podamos resolver pero no
hay que preocuparnos vamos a seguir
desarrollando algebraica mente aquí a
ver si sucede algo interesante va
entonces déjame poner que cf cf entre 9
es igual a y lo que voy a hacer aquí es
separar la fracción y / y es igual a 1
entonces es igual a 1 - menos x entre y
menos x x / g / g
y eso está muy padre porque aquí tenemos
el valor de x / y entonces déjame seguir
la igualdad de este lado entonces esto
es igual a 1 menos cf entre 12 c
entre 12 y observa que tenemos una
igualdad entre el primer término y el
último de esta forma
efe entre 9 es igual a 1 menos cf entre
12 y esto ya suena muy bien porque es
una ecuación en una variable y justo es
la variable que nos interesa entonces
vamos a seguir lo que vamos a hacer es
sumar cf entre 12 de ambos lados
entonces nos quedaría que s efe entre 9
más cf entre entre 12 es igual a 1 es
igual a 1 y ya casi terminamos verdad ya
nada más tenemos que sumar esta fracción
y despejarse efe entonces un buen
denominador común sería me parece que 36
entonces vamos a ponerlo por acá vamos a
poner el denominador común 36
eso de ahí va a ser igual a 1 y haber 9
por cuántos 36 pues nueve por cuatro
entonces aquí tendríamos cuatro veces cf
y luego pues doce por cuántos 36 pues
por por tres verdad 12 por 336 aquí hay
que sumar tres veces cf y entonces que
obtenemos a partir de esto cuatro cf3
cf6 siete cf entonces siete cf entre 36
entre 36 es igual a 1 es igual a 1 y ya
está verdad ya nada más hay que
multiplicar por el recíproco de 736
ambos de los dos lados entonces
multiplicamos por 36 entre 7 por 36
entre 7 esto se cancela es el chiste y
tenemos que cf cf es igual a 36 sobre 7
36 sobre 7 vale entonces con esto con
esto terminamos el problema y en
realidad es este problema está bien
padre porque nos dice algo muy
interesante
imagínate que a b y d
son postes o paredes o no sé qué es lo
que sea que son ha sido unas cosas
verticales y que amarramos un hilo de
aaee y otro hilo de de ave vale o sea
desde arriba de un poste hasta abajo del
otro y desde arriba de un poste hasta
abajo del otro entonces este problema lo
que nos dice es que no importa qué tan
lejos estén los postes verdad porque
aquí tenemos una longitud que nunca
utilizamos no importa qué tan lejos sean
que estén entonces la altura del punto
en el cual se cruzan las cuerdas siempre
va a ser igual a 36 séptimos eso a mí me
parece súper interesante espero que a ti
también y espero que te haya gustado
este problema de semejanza